Christa B Allen once played a younger
version of Jennifer Garner but these
days she's keeping busy by fueling
rumors on social media and becoming
royalty on a couple of cable
networks after 13 Going on 30 Christa B
Allen continued to work steadily during
her teenage years in 2006 for example
she landed the lead role in the CBS
children Series Cake she played the
title character who hosts the public
access arts and craft show with her
friend miracle and neighborhood kid Amy
the show within a show is shot in Cake's
garage and is directed by her friend
Benjamin cake lasted for only a single
13 episode season but its light Feelgood
story lines offered fun fodder for
Creative Kids many of the episodes were
just plain silly including one that was
solely about Miracle need to take a
shower after soccer practice however the
show occasionally touched on deeper
topics like natural disasters how to
handle conflict in goal- centered living
Allan even won a young artist award for
her work on the series cake may have
lasted only one season but in 2011 Allan
was cast on the ABC Drama revenge as
Charlotte Grayson through four seasons
on the show Charlotte experienced rehab
a lost pregnancy and difficult family
secrets Allan certainly appreciated the
opportunity as she told Refinery 29 it's
nice to be part of a show where I feel
like we have a really collaborative
environment I can always have input on
the show and the character Allan also
enjoyed playing Charlotte because she
felt that fans could appreciate the
character struggles as she told College
magazine we're all people on this earth
going through similar experiences it's
worth opening up to and realizing we're
all in the same boat together we're not
alone I think that's why people are
drawn to Revenge there's a character and
an experience that everyone can relate
to Allan booked a recurring gig on the
ABC Family sitcom baby daddy the series
focused on the character of Ben who's
raising his daughter with the help of
his brother Danny and a couple of
friends Allan joined the cast in season
4 as Danny's Corporate attorney
girlfriend Robin she also appeared in
several made for TV movies around this
time including the horror mystery one of
us and the Thriller dying for a baby 13
Going on 30 wasn't the only time that
Allan played a younger version of
Jennifer Garner 2009's ghosts of
girlfriend's past centers on Matthew
mccon as Connor me a womanizer haunted
by his former Flames the story was based
on the classic Charles Dickens Nolla A
Christmas Carol Garner and Allan both
played Jenny the only girl who ever
truly captured Connor's heart which he
realizes by the end of the film
unsurprisingly Allan has garnered to
thank for helping her to book this gig
as Alan revealed to Entertainment
Tonight in 2021 I will just say that me
playing her in Ghost of girlfriend's
past was a function of Jennifer speaking
up they were looking to cast the roll
and they were like we don't know what to
do we're trying to find a younger you
and Jen was like call up Christa she's
done this before and she's good at it in
addition to her regular and recurring
gigs Christa B Allen continued to hone
her acting chops and guest appearance on
a variety of TV shows from 2008 to 2010
she showed up on such hit programs as
graze Anatomy ER Cold Case and CSI in
each one she played a character
experiencing trauma specifically a car
accident victim an assault victim a
former girlfriend of a murder victim and
a poisoning victim these tragic roles
allowed Allan to really show off for
dramatic chops for example on graves
Anatomy she played a teenager who was
texting while driving got into to a
severe accident and eventually died she
followed up these guest star gigs with
other meaty roles like the Soapy TV
movie Deadly sibling rivalry she played
a girl named Fiona who suspects that her
mother's coma following a car accident
was caused by her evil Aunt how long you
think before that little girl figures
you out she doesn't know anything if
you're a regular viewer of the Lifetime
network chances are high that you've
seen Christa Allen on more than one
occasion she starred in multiple
lifetime original movies with titles
like when Val break and family of lies
in 2018s dangerous seduction also known
as the queen of sin she played posie
Pinkerton a responsible Doctor Who wants
to let loose before she gets married she
has a chance encounter with the
mysteriously Charming Jack who convinces
her to create an alter ego and thus the
queen of sin emerges as the queen of sin
posie explores her basist instincts
though she never truly gives into them
before finding a way back to her
inherent goodness she realizes that Jack
is evil after he helps to kidnap her
though her feelings for him are
complicated Allan oozes authenticity
despite the over-the-top storyline
although the actor got her starred in
comedy her adult roles have typically
been steeped in tragedy and drama in an
interview with Star constellation
magazine she admitted I've been told I
have resting sad face so I think it just
works I'd love to do more comedy in the
future Allen's experience with lifetime
isn't limited to soapy melodrama and
she's also been able to demonstrate her
acting chops in some timely layered role
roles in 2021 for example she starred in
the fight that never ends as Joanne Beck
a Jewish TV producer Who falls in love
with Jay Hunter a black gang leader
together they combat racial hatred and
give back to their Community set against
the backdrop of the South Central Los
Angeles riots in the wake of the Rodney
King beating the fight that never ends
explores how we can collectively combat
oppression to bring about equality it
also asks hard questions of its audience
that remain resonant today as Allan
noted in an interview with media Village
I'm immediately love the story and the
character of Joanne so much I would have
done anything to play this role there's
a need for good leadership in the world
today and I hope that people are
inspired by that aspect of the story
we're more powerful together 13 Going on
30 gave Christa B Allen her first major
film role as well as a lifelong
friendship Jennifer Garner took Allan
under her wing and gave her advice on
navigating Hollywood Allan still holds
Garner in high regard and when she
turned 30 herself in 2021 she used it as
an opportunity to reflect on their
friendship as as Allan revealed during
an interview on today grunner encouraged
her to make sure that she had a full
life outside of acting and to draw on
her own experiences to inform the
characters that she plays I think she
has this Persona of being very sweet and
kind and welcoming and she was that then
and she is that now Garner also took the
time to wish Alan a happy 30th birthday
on Instagram while simultaneously
shouting out their time together making
13 Going on 30 in addition to her acting
career Christa B Allen has launched into
a new Stratosphere as a social media
Creator on Tik Tok as of 2023 she's
amassed over 1.8 million followers and
more than 42 million likes on the
platform she launched her Tik Tok
account in the thick of the covid-19
pandemic and quickly gained a following
by posting makeup tutorials and videos
inspired by 13 Going on 30 in an
interview with allore about her new
found role as a beauty influencer she
admitted I'm super nosy about anything
to do with progress and Innovation if
there's new technology new developments
and Beauty I'm just curious in 2022
Allan sparked some rumors when she
posted a Tik Tok of herself and the
rapper The Game kissing however the game
went on the record with People magazine
and stated that the two shared mutual
friends but were never romantically
involved also in 2022 create and
cultivate named Allen as one of the top
10 C creators to follow the honor was
bestowed on 10 women who use their
unique voices and perspectives as social
influencers but the truth of the matter
is it's just media along with her steady
acting career and sizable social media
following Alan resume also includes
singer songwriter in 2018 she joined her
then boyfriend Johnny W in the studio to
record some music what is a member of
the alternative pop Trio Braves a band
whose members famously declin to show
their faces in videos or photos he's
also a music producer who has worked
with other bands like Fitz in the
Tantrums and walk the moon the couple
decided to collaborate under the moniker
of poor Vu as they laid down tracks
about love and relationships Allen's
lead vocals exude an ethereal quality
reminiscent of P heads Beth Gibbons in
an interview with Le Palm she discussed
her transition from acting to singing as
she noted with acting you can't get
anything done with less than 30 people
minimum there are a lot of more Hoops to
jump through so music is really
satisfying in that way it's like instant
gratification Allan and what released
all of their tracks as singles rather
than a ful length album in 2018 they
dropped six tracks although there's no
word about whether or not they'll ever
collaborate again in 2009 Christa B
Allen made her first appearance on the
Hallmark Channel in the TV movie chasing
a dream but it wasn't until 2021 that
she became part of the Network's holiday
family by starring in Christmas for
Keeps the plot follows alen as Avery
Taylor a woman who teams up with her old
group of high school friends to return
to her small town to celebrate the life
of Mr Massie their Drama teacher who
died unexpectedly Avery and her friends
sponsor a toy drive in Mr massie's honor
naturally enough there are all Enchanted
by the spirit of Christmas and Avery and
her childhood best friend reconnect and
fall in love although the the storyline
of Christmas for Keeps is predictable
Allan manages to infuse her performance
with plenty of
authenticity American actors who
regularly work in film and TV often tend
to live close to New York City or Los
Angeles as those cities are the two
major hubs of production however Christa
Allen has chosen to do things a little
differently by escaping the Hollywood
Limelight and relocating to Miami
Florida as she told Ocean Drive magazine
in 2023 in Miami we live and breathe
jadui we dance eat and soak up the
sunshine it seems like small things but
it really means the most to me so much
of the enjoyment of life gets lost in
the competitive nature of Los Angeles
and I needed a break Alan actually grew
up in Southern California and remained
in the area into adulthood as she found
steady acting work but now that she's
made her way to South Florida she often
showcases for Miami life on her
Instagram and Tik Tok as a social media
influencer Christa Allen unfailingly
injects her unique life perspective into
her posts whether she's promoting a
beauty product or posting a humorous
video she shares positive messages and
she loves to make sure that she takes
breaks from work to get in some playtime
for instance she captioned one Instagram
photo with a mission statement my wish
for my life is that I never stop playing
no matter my age creativity and learning
happen in Play I Will Never Let the
opinions of others stop me from
embracing the playful nature within that
serves my highest growth Allan continues
to explore her way through life without
letting her acting career dictate her
personal choices in a 2020 interview on
the podcast hey now hey now she shared
that she believes it's important to live
without regrets and it sure seems like
she's taking her own advice after 13
Going on 30 she managed to avoid the
obstacles that have befallen plenty of
other child actors before and after her
and now as an adult she keeps herself
active by branching out to multiple
forms of entertainment Beyond just
professional
acting